ihr Tweet wann war das gestern
vorgestern vielleicht könen können die
Kollegen aus der Regie den mal kurz
zuspielen das war sehr interessant da
haben Sie mal wieder richtig geholzt und
ausgeteilt wen die 60 Milliarden für
Wärmepumpen wenn die nicht kommen dann
wer wir wieder zu bewerrten Grundlage
zurückkehren müssen ein ster das ist ein
Raummeter ne Brennholz ersetzt 120 l
importiertes fossiles Heizöl und macht
im Gegensatz zu einer nicht eingebauten
Wärmepumpe warm genau das ist genau die
Situation in jetzt stecken was hat das
würden sie dann jetzt sagen das ist das
Konzept das ist auf alle Fälle besser
als das hab Konzept man hat die Ampel
hat uns ja im Sommer erklärt
Holzheizungen sollten verboten werden
braucht man nicht mehr es kommt jetzt
dann die Wärmepumpe für alle dann haben
die Leute aufgejaul und haben gesagt ihr
spinnt wohl das kostet mich 100.000 €
mit Sanierung des Hauses dann hat's
geheißen alle ruhig bleiben es gibt viel
viel Staatszuschuss und jetzt kommt eben
dieser Staatszuschuss nicht für das
Sanieren der Häuser
okaymp alleegen ich lieber mit holzizen
könen mit der wärmumpeen die nicht
kriegt weil der hab ich kein Geld mehr
hat bevor wir auch gleich Roman deinger
Fragen ger mal fren wie sieht denn ihr
Klimakonzept aus wie würden sie es denn
machen wie ist denn ihr Energie und
Wärmekonzept würden sie es machen wir
können nicht jetzt alle anfangen
Brennholz zu sammeln und vielleicht
wieder in Höhlen wohnen das das wollen
wir nicht na Brennholz und Höhle ist
nicht unbedingt die Kombi es hat ein
Drittel
sehr g nein wir haben Millionen von
Häusern in Deutschland haben Gott sei
Dank noch einen Kachelofen oder einen
Holzofen und wenn alle Stricke reißen
könnte man damit die Wohnung warm halten
als wir im letzten Winter diskutiert
haben kalt dususchen und in Waschlappen
waschen ist immer nur besser mit
holzheizen zweitens bin ich ein großer
Unterstützer der wasserstoffpolitik und
Herr Scholz hat ja sich ja mit der Frau
miloni geeinigt dass Sie hier die
wasserstoffpipeline aus dem Süden
kriegen wollen also ich bin überzeugt
wir müssen die Grundlast über
Wasserstoff abdecken wir hab sie ja
nicht ne wir bauen haben sie ja jetzt
nicht haben wir heute hier und heute
nicht aber wir müssen eben dann das
freing Wecken sie dann immer den
Eindruck dass wir das jetzt gerade haben
sie sagen sie schon zum fragen was mein
Konzept ist und nicht wie es heute ist
soll ich Ihnen erklären wie es jetzt ist
oder wie mein Konzept ist mein Konzept
ist nicht das wie es heute ist sondern
ich muss aus dem heute raus mein Konzept
entwickeln und mein Konzept heißt
vermehrt auf Wasserstoff zu setzen heißt
1000 Windräder in Bayern zu bauen heißt
Photovoltaik auszubauen wir sind
Spitzenreiter im PV Ausbau und damit
wird wir dann einen Großteil der
fossilen Energieträger ersetzen wenn wir
das nicht tun dann bricht die Wirtschaft
zusammen oder wir bleiben Fossil so
schaut's aus Herr Deininger ist das ist
das Hubert eanger in reheinultur was wir
gerade hier erleben also ich würde
zuerst mal sagen die rasante politische
Wende ist offenbar eine sehr bayerische
Kunstform im Gegensatz vielleicht zu
vorausschauender Energiepolitik das
würde auf CSU unfreie Wähler beziehen
bei den Trassen bei der CSU auch ganz
stark bei den windridern äh da hätte man
sich mehr Voraussicht gewünscht ich
glaube der Grund warum die schon
beginnend in der erre Seehofer nicht da
war ist dass man sich in der CSU
eiwanger tut das ja auch immer der Nähe
zu den Menschen rühmt aber die Menschen
wollen halt keine Zumutungen die suchen
oft zunächst einmal den einfachsten Weg
und wenn Politik äh notwendige Reformen
und Projekte nicht erklärt und den
Menschen vermittelt dann kommt's auch
nicht zustande und das wurde in Bayern
über viele Jahre von CSU und Freien
Wählern verpasst die Grünen machen
besser mal inen sch nicht zwingend
absolut n aber immerhin hat die Ampel
eine breite
reformagendahrinter genau die haben in
der politikerklärung versagt haben keine
Empathie gezeigt für die einfachen Leute
die von ihren Reformen betroffen sind
das ist das Scheitern der Ampel ich
möchte einmal ganz kurz auf den Tweet
eingehen weil sie da für mich ein
stückweit tatsächlich das Prinzip
eiwanger Spiegel und zwar einem guten
s sie das Eingangszitat ja also der
dialektraum am Rand am am Land den sie
ansprechen den sie ansprechen ich we
nicht sie sagen ich würde nur im
dialektraum funktionieren da hätten s
mich gerne nur dortst dass ich mich
ausweiteen
stad überhaupt gar keine Angst davor ich
hab gar kein lastenforderer D sie
wegnehmen können W
lassen die es ist doch eindeutig
Anh g was war das nur die Kette ausauen
W nur die Kette ausbauen vom
Lastenfahrrad nein aber die
Wahlergebnisse zeigen doch klar sagen
sie selber dass sie in Niederbayern toal
stark waren auch bei persönlichen Werten
dass das ins ins oberberische reingeht
und dass es in anderen Regionen eben
nicht ganz so stark war stark ber hab
keine Angst deswegen muss eine ber aber
g
gzz
nein ne das sage ich nicht Herr eiwanger
aber in ihrem Tweet spiegelt sicher dass
auf dem Land die Vernunft wohnt die
Menschen die sich selbst helfen können
mit dem sterholz mit dem S die Wohnung
warm kriegen während in der Stadt die
Leute quasi vor der
nicht funktionierenden oder nicht
eingebauten Wärmepumpe sitzen und
frieren müssen genau so war auch ein
Krieg dass die Städte aufs Land
kommen logisch gen also deswegen schaut
nicht immer so runter auf die Bauern
sondern seid froh dass ihr die habt ich
schaue niemals runter auf die Bauern ich
komm selber also familienmäßig eine
Generation zurück von bauerof ich glaub
der Fehler wenn ich das sagen darf WN
ich das so nennen darfang ist dass sie
versuchen zwischen Stadt und Land einen
klaren Trennstrich zu ziehen den so
nicht
gibt
Schweine natlich geschrieben einer vuch
geschrieben Niederbayern flyc also da
gehen am besten nicht raus GI
liche bayernakte die aus niederbern
kommen mit großer Wärme über diese
Region schreiben ich hab zB hab z.B
Verwandschaft bei Ihnen in der Nähe von
von Rottenburg in neufahen ich bin da
öfter bin beim beim Handball in
Rottenburg ich will dit sagen diese
Trennung funktioniert nicht jeder
Städter war vielleicht ein paar Jahre
bevor er nach München oder woanders
hinzogen ist ein Landkind und jeder
jeder vom Land fährt vielleicht gerne in
die Stadt das heißt diese Trennung
gefährlicher großstadjournalist sie sie
fahren ja diese Herabwürdigung des
Landes sie haben ja den eiwanger seit 10
Jahren als den schweinebau aus
Niederbayern bezeichnet aus der
süddeutchen wir haben Herr ewanger an
vielen Artikeln kann jetzt reden an den
nicht beteiligt waren da haben wir Ihre
besonderen politischen Qualitäten nah
bei den Leuten sein der themenriecher
das haben wir im Besonderen gewürdigt
wir haben ganze Seite dre üerschrieben
mit Gras wachsen hören das ist ihre
eigene Beschreibung ihrer Fähigkeit
Themen wahrzunehmen wir haben das durch
anerkannt aber wenn sie nicht kritisiert
werden wollen dann reden sie nicht so
wie in Erding wenn sie nicht kritisiert
werden wollen dann ziehen
Sie verswörungorien die
unhalt wo ist die Verschwörung ich habe
recht gehabt als ich gesagt habe die
reagieren oder regieren gegen die
Mehrheit und die sollen die Holzheizung
in Ruhe lassen und mit der Wärmepumpe
funktioniert nicht genau D
sind sie möglicherweise durchaus Recht
in der konkreten Sache Wärmepumpe aber
sie haben als bayerische Staatsvertreter
eine Verantwortung dafür welche Sprache
sie benutzen wie sie klingen welche
Botschaften sie senden und so eine
missverständliche
Formulierung ti der Süddeutschen dazu
sie wollen Süddeutsche dem eiwanger
sagen wie er zu reden hat ich muss
gewählt werden nicht sie kandidieren
doch
mal sind Zeitung wir haben unsere Stimme
die nutz dazu über die zu schreiben die
wirklich Macht haben Leute wie sie und
will ich will no ganz kurzchen sie
werden herrwanger sehr oft
missverstanden Demokratie zurückholen
haben sie gesagt ist ganz harmlos
gemeint einfach beim nächsten Mal bei
der nächsten Wahl die Mehrheit na ja
weil es in diesen sensi weil in diesen
sensiblen Zeiten sehr leicht
missverstanden werden kann und von den
falschen Leuten und sie werden sie
werden häufig missverstanden das kann an
allen anderen liegen die sie
missverstehen es kann aber auch an ihnen
liegen und schon langsam
mus die demoktie zurü hab nicht aufggt
wenn sagt demoktie
zurü als Robert habbeck mal den Satz
gesagt hab auf Bayern bezogen da muss
man die Demokratie wiederherstellen in
irgendeinem bayischen Wahlkampf da haben
wir das auch Miert das ist doch
selbstverständlich aber aber der hab hat
das auch nicht vor 10000 Leuten in
Erding am Volksfestplatz gemacht bei
einer Kundgebung sondern öffentlich in
den Medien für 100 Millionen kurz einmal
ein bisschen sortieren also das eine ist
ganz kurz vorne anzufangen flyover
country
tatsächlich stand in der Süddeutschen
Zeitung aber Herr deinger hat Recht wenn
er sagt ich habe das gelesen es war ein
gut geschriebener Artikel und das sie
haben gesagt voller Wärme und Liebe so
habe ich jetzt nicht empfunden aber aber
es war nicht böseartig es war nicht
böseartig nein ich habe es gelesen es
war war nicht
bösartig das zweite
ist Demokratie z sie sagen da werde ich
hoffe ich mverstanden wir haben uns ja
beide hier in der Sendung auch über
diesen Satz ausgetauscht und wir
erinnern Sie sich wie Sie die Demokratie
genannt haben die wir gerade hier haben
Erin sie sich daran sie haben auch aus
diesem Wort dann wieder was hinein
interpretiert hab ihen die ich hab ihnen
die Sache erklärt und sie wollten auch
wieder missverstehen nein sie haben nein
nein nein nein ich habe sie
gefragt ich nie behauptet dass
Deutschland jetzt keine Demokratie wäre
sondern ich hab immer gesagt ich bin
ja aber wissen Sie was Sie gesagt
habitte bitte ge sie geben Sie mir die
Chance das einmal sag geben Sie mir die
Chance das einmal zu sagen ich habe sie
gefragt ob das ihr ernst ist als sie
sind ja auch nicht ein
Oppositionspolitiker sind
stellvertretender bayerischer
Ministerpräsident so und als solcheer
haben sie es se ich wie Herr Deininger
eine Verantwortung das sieht glaube ich
auch jeder in der Runde hier so und das
sehen auch Leute so die zuschauen und
ich habe sie gefragt wie sie das meinen
und sie sagten damals mir unvergessen ja
wir haben natürlich eine Demokratie eine
formal
dem Frau bal dem verehen sie fr fr hat
gerade reagiert darauf wie wieen sie wie
finden sie
sozbb haben sie das gesagt dass wir eine
formale Demokratie haben aber keine
tatsächliche nein das habe ich nichtesag
keine tatsächliche was meinen Sie damit
dann wenn sie sagen wir haben eine
formale Demokratie wir eine Demokratie
haben unsere Staatsform ist eine
Demokratie aber die derzeit Regierenden
leben diese Demokratie nicht richtig
sondern regieren gegen die Mehrheit
regieren bei vielen Themen gegen die
Mehrheit sei das selbstbestimmungsgesetz
SE ist das heizungsgesetz gewesen sie
regieren gegen die Mehrheit das war
meine Aussage aber ganz kurz Frau sie
dürfen
sofort
letztendlich wenn sie sagen Herr
eiwanger die Wirtschaft dieses Landes
ist sehr wichtig und wir können nicht
zusehen dass sie den Bach untergeht ja
da müssen sie doch auch erkennen dass
der gesellschaftliche Zusammenhalt
dieses Landes mindestens genauso wichtig
ist wie die wir ich mich ein aber nicht
wenn sie der jetzigen Regierung
unterstellen sie sei nur eine formale
Demokratie weil genau das ist ja auch
die Botschaft wir hatten das in den
ganzen letzten Jahren bei den Querdenker
Demonstrationen bei den Menschen die den
Medien unterstellen dass wir alle
gelenkt und geleitet werden und ich
finde tatsächlich da geht es um
Verantwortung und wenn sie wirklich das
Interesse haben dieses Land
voranzubringen müssen sie glaube ich
auch komplexer denken vielleicht geht es
dann nicht nur um ihr
stammwählerpublikum sondern vielleicht
geht es auch darum über das ganze Land
zu schauen auch mit so einer
Formulierung das tue ich mehr als die
Ampel und deswegen schlage ich Alarm
weil die dieses Land an die Wand fahren
wirtschaftlich und politisch in der Zeit
der Ampel ist die AFD so stark geworden
wie nie zuvor weil sie billiges Futter
kriegen durch die Ampel weil die Ampel
hier jeden Fehler macht mit Ansage in
jedes Fettnäpfchen springt mit dem
heizungsgesetz und jetzt mit all diesen
Versprechungen im Klimaschutz nicht
liefern kann weil sie das Geld nicht
organisiert das ist alles alles sie
dürfen das alles sagen und es ist alles
völlig in dankeön dass ich sagen nein
nein ich meine na bitte nicht so gemeint
sie wissen die Kritik ist doch völlig
berechtigt und die ist auch in Ordnung
es geht ja wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe und ich habe gleich noch
ein anderes Beispiel für Sie es geht um
die Sprache es geht um die Art und Weise
wie wir miteinander reden und Frau Bali
finde ich hat einen guten Punkt wenn sie
sagt wenn es jetzt gerade darum geht
dass wir alle gemeinsam die Ärmel
hochkrempeln dann finde ich müssen wir
ein bisschen auf die Sprache achten und
die Art und Weise ob wir also
tendenziell einfach nur noch
gegeneinander schießen oder ob wir es
irgendwie miteinander versuchen wollen
und sie als noch mal Wirtschaftsminister
und stellvertretender bische
Ministerpräsident sie sind nicht
irgendwer und sie sind eben nicht sie
machen Sie kckettieren dann immer damit
und sag benimkurs hier wird benimkurs
mit ma nicht lächerlich llich aber sie
kommen mit dem mit der Ansage was der
eiwanger sagen darf ich bin me wäh
verpflichtet oder
wieer hier in die Grüze in dieser
Republik und derwer soll immer gezähmt
werden jetzt mit Mühe und Not dass er
nur bayerisch reden darf dass er nur
hier
und darf ich darf ich ganz kurz Tweet
von heute glaube ich gestern gestern von
gestern vielleicht könen wir den einm
kurz ze taucht wieder so ein Wort auf wo
ich
denke also deutschland muss sich auf
seine eigene Zukunftsfähigkeit
konzentrieren die Geldkoffer für
ideologische Träumereien sind leer alles
gut und irgendwann erlmt die
Arbeitsmoral der gutwilligen auch gut
wenn sie merken dass sie für und von und
jetzt kommt taugenichtzen ausgenutzt
werden wissen sie D ein Taugenichts ist
ja einer der viel redet und nicht
liefert und einer der nichts tut ein
nichtsnutziger Mensch ist das einer der
nichts taugt aber anderin R
nichtnutziger Mensch ist das jemand der
nichts taugt ist er tauge nichts wer ist
das für die dutenefinition ist interess
ein Mensch der zu nichts nütze ist na ja
jetzt wollen sie auf die Nummer raus ein
tauge nicht ist doch im Sprachgebrauch
ganz genau jemand der auf Kosten der
anderen lebt der sich selber nicht
einbringt der sich unsozial verhält das
ist ein tauge nichts den man zu nichts
brauchen kann der anderen drein redet
und sie wissen genau an wen denken sie
da das sind beispielsweise
bürgergeldempfänger die arbeitsfähig
wären und eine zumutbare Arbeit ablehnen
das ist nicht der bürgergeldempfänger
der wirklich bedürftig ist der krank ist
und so weiter sondern das ist einer der
auf Kosten der anderen lebt obwohl er
anders könnte und ein taugen nichts ist
auch jemand der in einer Regierung sitzt
keinen Schulabschluss hat den Leuten
erzählt und selber noch nie gearbeitet
hat und am Ende Dinge an die Wand fährt
auch das ist an wen denken Sie jetzt
konkret ja Brau ich keine Namen nennen
vielleicht fen fallen ihnen selber
einige ein sagen sie doch das andere
habe ich gesagt Bürgergeld na weil ich
dann angezeigt werd vielleicht niemand
also sie sagen Dinge von denen sie
befürchten müssen dass sie dafür
angezeigt werden keine Ahnung aber wie
gesagt von von sie sagen das ja ich sag
ich sag auch regierende es gibt auch
regierende tauge
nichtze in diesem Land ja an wen denken
Sie dabei können sie sich ausmalen
äh Herr Brücker bitte ich habe sie
vorhin unterben ja ich versuch mal
vermitteln einzuen eiwanger ich habe sie
als sanfter Populist bezeichnen weil ich
ja an das Gute demokratische gehen in
ihn sehr Glaube und es gut finde wenn
Opposition oder jetzt in dem Fall
Regierungspolitiker auf die Missstände
hinweisen aber man muss akzeptieren dass
in einer Demokratie eine demokratisch
legitimierte Regierung sogar vier Jahre
lang gegen alle Mehrheiten in dieser
Republik regieren dürfte und ein
Gesetzen ja ich will einmal zu Ende
sagen und deswegen ist dieser Satz
formale Demokratie noch schlimmer als
dieser sehr schwierige Begriff tauge
nichts weil sie Menschen natürlich
herabwürdigen indem sie einen tauge
nichts ist einer der zu nichts taugt
also herabwürdigen und ich finde einfach
wir haben Soziologen nennen das so ein
querfronten Problemem weil ganz
verschiedene Gruppen gerade sich gegen
die da oben gegen die Elite gegen die
etablierten schwören mit ganz
schwierigen darüber reden wir sicherlich
auch
nochös die sich in
Parallelgesellschaften abgeschottet
haben die es eben nicht nur im
islamischen muslimischen Bereich gibt
sondern leider auch in verschiedenen
deutschen Gruppierungen und dieses gegen
die befördern demokratische Politiker
wie sie und eigentlich wünscht man sich
dass jemand wie sie ja die Finger in die
Wunde legt aber nicht so übertreibt dass
er dadurch einen Diskurs völlig enthemmt
und unmöglich macht und das ist ein
Beispiel wo sie dem Nahrung geben Herr
eiwanger das müssen sie doch sehen dass
das keine Begriffe sind wo sie irgendwie
zusammenführen man kann doch kritisieren
ohne verächtlich machen zu müssen oder
Häme anzubringen das doch der Punkt
formale Demokratie ist doch ein Witz an
sich formale Demokratie das gibt es
nicht wir haben eine Demokratie und Sie
müssen akzeptieren dass die Ampel das
macht wenn sie Recht haben dann wird die
Ampel abgewählt in zwei Jahren wenn die
angeblich gegen die Mehrheit die ganze
Zeit Regierung dann wird sie abgewählt
aber deswegen muss man ihn nicht
unterstellen dass dass sie quasi
Lustgefühle dabei hätten gegen die
Mehrheit der Deutschen zu
regen nein aber formale Demokratie ich
bin es ist einfach ein so ich wür auch
gerne etwas dazuagür erst Herr deer ganz
ganz ganz kurzer Punkt erstens ist es
misslich wenn ein hoher Staatsvertreter
seine Worte das was er sagt oft
nacherklären muss das ist einfach kein
kein g kein g kein es verstehen s jetzt
hier in der Runde z.B ziemlich viele
Miss und das zweite ist und das hat
Michael Bröcker gerade schon hergeleitet
ich glaube dass es politische Führung
ist dass man andere politische
Positionen auch wenn man sie nicht teilt
auch wenn man sie vielleicht sogar
bekämpft mit Respekt behandel weil man
damit das Signal in die Bevölkerung
sendet dass er gutes Miteinander gute
Debatte möglich ist diese Art von
politischer Führung leisten sie nicht
und das trägt nicht zu einer guten
politischen Kultur in diesem Land bei
und tut mir persönlich leid herrwanger
weil ich quasi ihre Rolle in Bayern
immer durchaus positiv gesehen habe sie
hätten eine integrierende Figur der
konservativen Mitte sein können in
diesem Jahr 2023 mit der Erdinger Rede
und der flffäre sind sie eine eher
spaltende Figur Richtung Rand geworden
und das ist traurig die
Flug D sofortwanger kommen wir jetzt
sofort dazu Frau bal sie wollten gerade
ich versuche ja Menschen auch immer
ernst zu nehmen wenn sie mir vermitteln
wollen dass Sie diese Gesellschaft nicht
spalten wollen aber wenn ich das lese
oder höre geht es ihnen wahrscheinlich
in ihrem politischen Profil eher darum
das Profil zu schärfen indem sie genau
so scharf schießen wie sie das tun aber
nicht wirklich nach Lösung zu suchen und
genau das ist das Problem denke ich wenn
Ihnen dieses Land wirklich was bedeutet
dann müssen sie da weiter aufgestellt
sein und breiter denken wenn wir von
taugenichtzen sprechen müssen wir uns
wirklich im Klaren sein darüber was wir
damit auch für eine Botschaft senden an
Menschen die sich dadch angesprochen
fühlen ja sowohl angesprochen fühlen
weil sie ihre Rhetorik gut finden ja als
auch angesprochen fühlen weil sie wissen
dass sie damit gemeint sind weil sie
eben nicht durch ihre Erwerbstätigkeit
in der Lage sind das G zu verdienen was
Sie brauchen um zu leben und wenn sie
mit ihrer schwarz-weißmalerei glauben
dass sie dieses Land hier voranbringen
kann ich Ihnen nur sagen haben andere
vorhin auch schon versucht hat bis heute
nicht geklappt ganz im
Gegenteil deswegen glaube ich auch nicht
dass wenn sie sagen dass was wir hinein
interpretieren wollen ist hier das Thema
sondern das was Sie sagen wollen und das
was sie sagen und das ist nicht das
einzige Zitat dass man dafür heranziehen
kann ist glaube ich recht klar Herr
eiwanger ja es ist eben
Zusammenhalt um den es für sie geht in
dieser ges Zusammenhalt ich kann ja die
Dinge nicht beschönigen reden es mal mit
den Leuten draußen die mittleren
lohnsegment unterwegs sind die mittleren
lohnsegment unterwegs sind und sehen
dass Leute Bürgergeld bekommen die
Arbeiten könnten aber sagen ich bin doch
nicht blöd für die paar Euros mehr
arbeite ich nicht das sind für mich
taugenichze die das System ausnutzen die
muss man benennen sonst fliegt uns der
Laden bald um die Ohren ich kann doch
nicht die Dinge gesund beten und dem die
arbeitet sagen na ja so schlimm ist
nicht sei froh dass du n gesund bist und
arbeiten kannst und der andere lacht
sich an Ast wir müssen diese Leute auch
zur Arbeit animieren die heute nichts
arbeiten kann man ja Thema dass sie das
Thema ansprechen wollen dass Sie das
Thema angehen wollen und dass sie eine
gewisse Bürgernähe dabei haben wollen
und auch eine stammtischretorik haben
wollen das sind alles Dinge die man
vielleicht noch verstehen kann aber dass
sie es so tun wie sie es tun dafür habe
ich absolut kein Verständnis weil es ist
eine
ganz le tollen sie mü genau und da sehen
sie ja das ist eine Demokratie wir leben
in einer ganz realen demok nehmen Sie
das zur Kenntnis D ist wie ist und wenn
sie sagen sie wollen mit mir nichts zu
tun haben sie müssen mich nicht wählen
Sie können viele andere parteen wähenum
geht doch gar nicht natlich geht nein
der Punkt ist das was Sie ansprechen der
Mechanismus um den es geht die Tatsache
dass dass Bürgergeld möglicherweise
nicht der perfekte Anreiz ist um Leute
in den Arbeitsmarkt zu bringen ich weiß
nicht Herr Brücker war an ze Sendungen
bet in den wir genau darüber sehr klar
und auch sehr hart gesprochen haben in
den wir ampelvertreter sehr hart genau
dafür kritisiert haben aber die ändern
trotzdem nichts also müssen es deutlich
angesprochen werden dieamp aber wenn sie
taugen nicht zu schreiben glauben sie
dann ändern Sie was probieren wir es
mal ernsthaft sie sind doch jetzt nicht
einfach irgendjemand der hier sitzt und
irgendwie so seine Meung also der Titel
brennt in Deutschland ich glaube dass
die Zeit vorbei ist wo wir schöne
trunden halten und dann heim gehehen und
uns alle wieder lieb haben das Land geht
den Bach runter wenn wir so weitermen
wir müssen die Probleme jetzt endlich
mal ein Lösung zuführen wollen sie
eigentlich den Laden zusammenhalten oder
wollen sie spalten natürlich natürlich
ich glaube dass der Laden momentan
gespalten wird durch diese Politik
schauen S in Bayern wo ich mitreiere
haben wir noch die größte Zustimmung zu
Regierung haben noch die größte
Zufriedenheit in der Bevölkerung das
Chaos haben wir nicht in Bayern sondern
in
berlinang jeder soziologiestudent lernt
im ersten Semester dass solche Reaktion
ja das Gegenteil bei den Gegnern aus
sie wir die ampelp verändern wollen dann
wird natürlich so nicht gelingen es
erzeugt es erzeugt ja Gegenreaktion ich
bin für die Kraft des Arguments es wird
Änderung an diesem Bürgergeld geben
warten Sie mal ab weil immer mehr
Experten immer mehr auch konstruktiv
argumentierende experten sagen das
Lohnabstandsgebot wird nicht mehr
eingehalten wir haben ein Problem mit
Flüchtlingen die nicht arbeiten das
Thema wird jetzt auch angegangen hören
Sie Hubertus Hal jetzt zu und hören Sie
V halben Jahr zu hören Sie frauer jetzt
zu ja es bewegt sich aber doch nicht
inem wir Menschen als tauge nicht zu
beschimpfen sondern indem wir immer mehr
das Argument in die Gesellschaft bringen
und sich immer mehr dem anschließen und
dann sind es plötzlich
Regierungspolitiker die heute wirklich
anders reden als vorm halben Jahr beim
Thema Migration beim Thema
Arbeitsanreize neämlich nur diese beiden
spdminister die heute etwas anderes
sagen als vorm halben Jahr es
funktioniert aber doch nicht indem wir
Menschen beschimpfen was für ein Bild
haben sie da im Kopf wenn sie taugen
nichts in ihr Handy tippen ja Leute die
auf Kosten der anderen bis mittags im
Bett liegen und dann sagen wenn die so
dumm sind und für mich arbeiten hole ich
mein Bürger aber sie auch Politiker im
Kopf ja wir haben auch Politiker im Kopf
die den Leuten welche Dinge
erzählen nie gearbeitet kein
Schulabschluss welche Partei können Sie
auch drüber nachdenken W sie die finden
Welte sie reden sie von Kevin sind
schlau genug da selber sich ein paar
auszumalen auf die diese beschreib reden
sie von von Ricard reden sie von Kevin
küner von wem reden
sie paar interessante Namen genannt
hier an wen an denken Sie an die ich
habe an niemand konkreten gedacht
sondern nur an Politiker die keinen
Schulabschluss haben den andere in die
Welt erklären wollen und selber noch
nichts geleistet haben es sind
politische tauge
nichtse